Frank Herbert's "Dune" series deals with
the plight of the Fremen people and their
struggle to stop intergalactic overlords
from mining their planet to death. The Fremen
serve as "Dune's" emotional center and provide
its narrative backbone. This is their story.
Frank Herbert didn't create this
desert culture out of whole cloth.
He drew inspiration from a healthy mix
of world religions and several actual
indigenous cultures on Earth. In particular,
he looked at the way that these peoples managed
to make a life for themselves in places
that might be considered inhospitable.
Herbert was compelled to write Dune after
hearing of a project by the United States
Department of Agriculture that would stop
Oregon's marching sand dunes from moving.
The USDA planted different kinds of grass
along the dunes to calm their movements,
as the blowing sand could wreak
havoc on nearby roadways and towns.
Herbert decided to contrast the
government's response of changing
the landscape with the way that native
people across Earth have historically
learned to live in harmony with
the planet's natural processes.
The Empire of Dune came to represent these
outsiders reshaping worlds in ways that make
them more profitable, while the Fremen stood in
for the ideas of harmonious living. Herbert based
the Fremen in large part on the San people who
live in the Kalahari desert. Like the Fremen, the
San learned to conserve water in order to survive
in some of the most unforgiving terrain on Earth.
The Fremen are descendants of a persecuted
religious group called the Zensunni Wanderers.
This nomadic group fled across the void of space
to evade imperial violence. Herbert created their
religion from the combined tenets of Sunni
Islam and his own belief in Zen Buddhism.
Their final stop was Arrakis,
a barren desert planet believed to be worthless
before the discovery of a spice called melange.
"He who controls the spice controls the universe!"
This spice gave all who consumed it a minor
amount of prescience. It quickly became
crucial for navigating ships in a galaxy
that had created faster-than-light travel.
So, the Fremen found themselves in a familiar
situation to anyone who knows about the Amazon
rainforest or the so-called American
frontier. They were the people living
on top of a coveted natural resource, and they
suffered in similar ways to those indigenous
peoples on Earth.
The Fremen were viewed as backward and savage
by Dune-colonizing outsiders. Their culture
was an example of the ways in which humanity
can survive in the least probable situations.
Because of the extreme scarcity of water on
the surface of their planet, a huge chunk
of Fremen culture and ritual is based around the
collection and conservation of this vital mineral.
They travel the surface of Dune dressed in
stillsuits, full-body coverings that collect
and filter sweat, respiratory droplets,
and waste, and store it in catch-pockets.
This water is then recycled via tubes that are
pumped through levers in the stillsuit's heels.
In this perfectly closed system,
not a drop of water is wasted.
The Fremen conception of wealth also revolves
around the collection of water. They live
in small bands that move between underground
sietches, where they store their water communally.
Individuals wear jewelry that symbolize their
share of the water. When Fremen die, their
bodies are rendered in a holy ceremony, and their
water is added back to the wealth of the tribe.
The Fremen have also managed a cautious
coexistence with the desert's greatest threat:
sandworms. Called "makers" by the Fremen, the
massive creatures tunnel through the desert sand
and appear at the slightest noise. Fremen
learn at a young age how to walk through
the desert in a sliding, arrhythmic gait
that mimics the natural settling of sand.
They do this to avoid drawing sandworm attention
— unless they're looking to hitch a ride.
That's right: The Fremen also have a
strategy for riding the sandworms of Dune.
It's a dangerous maneuver that allows them
to cover massive stretches of the desert at
a clip. This technique is a closely
guarded secret of their community.
Though the Empire believes
that they are few in number,
the truth is that a massive society
has blended into the desert.
"My Lord, I suspect an incredible
secret has been kept on this planet,
that the Fremen exist in vast numbers."
From the safety of their underground sietches,
the collected Fremen have been working
on a generational terraforming project.
Their goal is to eventually transform
Dune into a verdant and hospitable planet.
This secret society of desert nomads provides
an army lying in wait for Paul Atreides,
who assumes the Fremen name Muad'dib, to
invade the polar port city of Arrakeen.
In the real world, mu'addib is Arabic for teacher.
During the epic Dune saga,
an imperial governor on Dune is overthrown
by a scheming family looking to settle a
blood feud. The son of that governor escapes to
the desert with his mother, the Lady Jessica.
Jessica takes advantage of prophecies
that had been seeded among the Fremen
by a holy order known as the Bene
Gesserit to which she belongs.
Using this Missionaria Protectiva, she coerces
the Fremen into accepting her son as their
messiah. His name is Paul Atreides, but he quickly
assumes a Fremen name meaning "kangaroo mouse."
The Fremen admire this creature for its
ability to live on the surface of Dune.
It's Paul's reciprocal embrace of Fremen
traditions that leads him to the spice and
the awakening of his dormant powers
of prescience. Without the Fremen,
Paul and Jessica might never have
survived their exile to the desert.
They certainly wouldn't have been able to
mount an assault on Harkonnen Arrakeen.
Paul became a true messianic figure
during his time among the Fremen.
The boy had been trained by his mother
in the weird arts of observation,
perception, and control practiced by the
Bene Gesserit witches for generations.
This all-woman mystical order exerts influence
by subtly molding the genealogy of Great Houses.
They then insert their converts into
bloodlines in the hopes of creating
their own messiah known as the Kwisatz
Haderach. This figure would be able
to access areas of prescience that the
Bene Gesserit witches could not reach.
"This is the place they cannot look."
In short, generations of witches had worked to
eventually create a son who would be trained
in their ways. Though Paul's mother had
not been given the go-ahead to train Paul,
she trained him anyway knowing that he would be
killed by the forces allied against their family
if he was not prescient. When these powers
combined with Paul's training as a Fremen,
he became a mystic desert dweller who could
see the future and use it to reshape Dune.
Paul then uses an army of Fremen,
who heard his revolutionary message,
to destroy the precious spice
that facilitates all space travel.
He simultaneously attacks the Empire's outposts,
while holding the galaxy's spice supply hostage.
The Emperor is forced to cave to Paul Muad'Dib,
who becomes the undisputed ruler of Dune.
Even though Paul is revered as a
god in the flesh by the Fremen,
history quickly slips out of his control. The
reverence and religious fervor surrounding
Muad'Dib transforms into a cosmic jihad waged in
Paul's name. It's fought and led almost entirely
by his army of Fremen fedaykin warriors with the
backing of his religious order, the Qizarate.
Hundreds of worlds and billions of people
come under the sway of Paul's empire in the
early days of his reign. A religion grows
around him and the Fremen homeworld of Dune
becomes a kind of space-age Jerusalem.
Paul's prescience shows him where this
path is headed. But he becomes hemmed in by his
future visions and his status as the godhead. So,
Paul is essentially paralyzed to act in any way
that might assure his people's enduring salvation.
Among the Fremen, there is an undercurrent
of dissent from older veterans of Paul's war
who don't like the way that
Fremen culture is changing. As
Paul makes water more available, older Fremen look
on in horror as the strict codes observed
by previous generations begin to disappear.
In addition to that, the fedaykin
become disillusioned with the war
effort when they come home to meager pensions
and comfortable suburban homes that carry
little trace of the harsh life of the sietch.
A plot is hatched among these Fremen
dissenters to assassinate Paul.
These rebels are egged on by the Spacing Guild
who have lost their unfettered access to the
spice melange. The Bene Gesserit witches, who
have lost control over their breeding program,
also encourage the revolt. Paul sees
these machinations in his visions,
but has trouble figuring out how to avoid the
plots bearing fruit without causing more misery.
Ultimately, he allows himself to be
grievously wounded by the Fremen dissenters.
He is blinded by a nuclear blast near the
holy city — an attack that he foresaw. The
strict Fremen way of life holds
that anyone who loses their sight
must wander out into the desert and allow himself
to die, rather than slowing down the tribe.
Though Paul is an emperor and could
have carried on without his sight,
he sees in this path a way off the treadmill
carrying him toward the Fremen's ultimate demise.
In sacrificing himself pursuant to traditional
Fremen law, he silences the doubts of the
traditionalist hardliners who worried that
he had forgotten the ways of the Fremen.
Under the 3,500-year reign of Paul's son
Leto II, the Fremen culture grows faint.
By merging with sand trout, a kind of
larval stage of the great sandworms,
Leto II becomes a nearly immortal human-sandworm
hybrid. He rules long enough to realize the
great dream of Liet-Kynes to terraform
Dune into a moist, temperate planet.
Leto is ultimately killed
by one of his descendants,
a Fremen-Atreides named Siona who has evolved
the ability to hide from his power of foresight.
Siona's assassination of Leto sets off the "Great
Scattering." This is an event that sees the many
peoples of the former empire dispersed in a
galactic diaspora. Without access to the spice,
they are essentially isolated for thousands
of years on their planetary islands.
When the peoples of the Scattering return,
one particularly violent sect — The Honored
Matres — bombards the surface of Dune with
planet-destroying weapons. These weapons,
called Obliterators, kill the last remnants of the
Fremen civilization. In Frank Herbert's original
series of six novels, only one Fremen escapes the
scouring of Dune. This is a girl named Sheeana,
a name derived from the original Fremen "Siona,"
and a mainline descendant of Paul Atreides.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.